he's a Jon Gruden kind enough to join us
as we recap episode 1 of hard knocks
coach did you watch the episode I'll
tell you what man I did you take a look
at those Derek Carr arms nobody wears a
red quarterback don't hit me shirt
better than Derek Carr those arms
that's that lotion that they said he
wanted to put the little white stuff on
his nose I tell you what man
nobody's gonna hitch in the nose you're
Derek Carr you're nothing
you're not in my dreams I want you in
people's nightmares man Freddie Krieger
that guy you know what I'm talking about
are you all in on this team they would
have loved these guys man
and if I don't if I don't love them I'll
trade oh man well you did say that like
Ronald alley you just cut him like he
liked to effort man you got to put the
effort in Dan if the dance if your guys
back there on the other side of the
glass are not doing their job you're
getting rid of those guys we want guys
who want to play we don't want guys
we're out there going half-speed who
can't even do a log roll and some type
of tumbling class we want guys who can
make it happen if they took this isn't
the this isn't the Outback Bowl this
isn't the Sugar Bowl this isn't the
Bluebonnet Bowl isn't none of that stuff
man yeah you surprised me with the
Bluebonnet Bowl that's a really old
reference there well you remember you
want me to go how about the AOL Instant
Messenger boys want that master bowl you
want that okay an American Airlines Bowl
how about the Borders bookstore Pole you
love those dance
those are great bowls those are bowls I
remember I tell you what man the world
just be different now it's gonna be back
at the same because I'm brewing this
thing okay all right that's a great
point that you brought up I did why
didn't you address why wasn't it
addressed on the show Antonio Browns
feet we still don't know how he got
these blisters yeah I'll tell you what
man those uh those those feet are so
scary they can't even show them on HBO
man that's part of the problem
you thought you could see it you've seen
they were what's that what's
at show they did their the Game of
Thrones man yeah got Game of Thrones
this was too crazy for Game of Thrones I
mean you can't add that stuff on
television but I'll tell you what it
Antonio Brown he's got to fix those feet
or we're gonna be in for fixing
ourselves man uh you got a rookie safety
there who you know Jonathan Abrams he he
likes to he likes to chattel he could be
crazy he stirs the pot a little bit
doesn't yes any talk back to him I don't
I - I with me see that yes I die
staredown contest I didn't blink Abers
blink you know I eat blink because I
don't blink man I just used my power of
teloth atelic allopathy maybe sure if
that's a word but tell it is it
telepathy
whatever man why the old days I had to
Rico I'd say Mike what is that and
Theresa come up with an idea what it was
we don't have Mike Tirico sitting next
to the human to Saurus the man with the
dictionary in his head that stuff
changes sean mcdonagh did a nice job but
Mike Tirico I think he had Google glass
on those were regular glasses there it
was nice to see some old videos though
of you know the previous greats John
Madden seeing him with the blocking sled
that was nice that was nice to see I'll
tell you what that I don't know what was
going on there but in true John Madden
form he didn't just tell you about the
seven man sled
he got on the seven man sled and then he
demonstrated what it was like to be a
coach on the seven men sled he kept
doing that right right right right right
that thing he sit there I thought there
was a glitch on the web feed man that
was tremendous I loved watching John
Madden all over the history all
everything behind what's going on here
with the Oakland Raiders this is I'm
tearing up here man
what can we you okay yeah what can we
expect with you know the next episode of
hard knocks I think it's just going to
get I think I think what's going to
happen is it's going to escalate man
we're going to start seeing when we
start
pads on we start hitting you see us
going up against other teams we're going
to start like I told Abrams man I said
hey don't you're not hitting anybody
with no pads get the other guys you go
hon 100% mental right now 50% physical
we play other teams we're going 100
percent maybe 200 percent maybe 300
percent maybe 400 percent I don't care
how many percentage is over 100 but it's
going to be tremendous man it no more
hot-air balloons from a be an
afterburner thing coming in at chopper
man that's gonna be a pretty good we're
gonna make it we're gonna make it happen
man well coach thank you very much it's
great to talk to you we appreciate your
time and hopefully we'll get a chance to
talk to you during the season absolutely
man I'm gonna go work on my
colloquialisms and sayings man all right
that's the great Jon Gruden Raiders head
coach by the way if you're interested in
this and i am frank caliendo's doing a
full weekly recap of every Hard Knocks
episode at Frank pods dot-com so just a
coincidence that I mentioned that with
Jon Gruden joining us nothing to do with
the appearance nope
so Frank is doing a full recap of every
Hard Knocks episode at Frank
Todd's calm for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at
[Music]